[Music]
they're unarmed but one of them has just
been shot he may still be alive they
grabbed him to take him away the
military fired tear gas and live rounds
the protesters just kids really charged
forward
ignore the firing other protesters are
in alleyways you can just about hear
them there are more shot the others
emerged
[Music]
this is Sudan's uprising the Sudanese
youth led revolution that's on the cusp
of change in the course of the nation's
history started in places like this in
dusty small communities they stood up
and said enough it cost the lives of
many a mural of Abdul Azim Abel Becker
the boys shot in the video is painted on
the wall of his family home on January
the 24th he stood alone for freedom as
others ran for cover this is the first
time it's brother sister and cousin have
spoken about his death it's remembered
every day and I'm very proud to be your
sister as my father would say he made us
proud in life and in death I miss him
dearly
despite being educated the family like
so many a dreadfully poor the revolution
here was born in poverty it's why it
happened Sudan deserves much more than
this it was not only Abdullah there are
thousands of they all died so Sudan can
be liberated and become good again my
fizzle Mahmoud Menino everyone would
want to avenge their brother's death we
want retribution
but we also want a better Sudan the two
brothers sister and cousin all took to
the streets but they never told each
other until now incredibly they did it
alone while sad none of them have
regrets about what happened to Abdul
Azim any English hello my Hanafy we wish
those who died were here with us to
witness the changes that are happening
but it's God's will
they were not here what happened in
Sudan was worth the sacrifice of our
lives our homeland is precious and we
love Sudan it was necessary for people
to sacrifice everything revolution isn't
yet won but they believe it's near a new
Sudan is within the grasp of those who
lived Stewart Ramsay Sky News on demand